what hey what's up beautiful babies
welcome to another episode of get close
I am Geo and I'm Bart what's up Bart
Bart Quan do you think it's CUNY that
attacker calls me about my first and
last name I think it's CUNY but I also
think he's a disrespectful little [ __ ]
isn't that the hard part of parenting
it's like he's so CUNY but then he's
also like you're like [ __ ] if this take
carries on for too long you're gonna get
in trouble and he gets used to it right
and then now because I had all this CUNY
time with him I laugh with them at the
Halloween party called no that's like
like 80 of good happy time then the one
time I'm like hey taka don't forget to
put your pants on okay but Juan I'm like
okay now how do I how do I say that all
the other times we're okay but this time
is not okay you know yeah what's so
interesting is that you're such a black
and white person and you tend to be
pretty rigid in your ways no that when
it comes to taika you have the hardest
time being rigid because he's so CUNY
like so right now we're trying to do
keto with him right like also
what
can I finish yeah go ahead so right now
we're also trying to do keto with him uh
so that we can uh slowly wean him off of
medication and just heal him through
food yeah and we both feel bad that like
keto is such a stringent diet and it's
so strict and it's so calculated it's
like you know it's like this amount of
fats almost no Pro sorry this amount of
fat this amount of protein almost no
carbs yeah and we all know all the yummy
snack food that he loves is all carbs
AKA childhood yes AKA childhood it might
as well call it call it uh childhood
child yeah they should have called it
Bart's mom's diet yeah yeah
okay I thought that was going to hit a
little bit harder yeah I would say don't
ever say that ever again oh [ __ ] yeah my
bad
um
what was I saying oh yeah so then you
you always have like this like oh but he
could probably do it on the weekends or
all that like we could give him this and
I'm like oh
what is that why why'd you turn into old
Asian man oh a racist one at that oh
okay I didn't say that yeah okay tired
as a person oh true
um no that I'm just like oh okay like he
uh he's got a soft spot for himself it's
hard because
um
so one my childhood sucked right so I
want to make sure he doesn't have my
childhood so that's why I'm in his life
baby that's it that's true Mexicans know
how to have a [ __ ] good mother
month of time regardless of what we're
doing we're always having a good time
you know what's so funny we would go
through like the poorest of Mexican
neighborhoods right like literally the
poorest we would go through it me and my
mom oh we're driving through right
literally the poorest and then I'll see
people's birthday parties and then
they'll have like the Bounce House the
pinata and all that stuff I'm like Mom
can I have that for my birthday party my
mom's like that's for rich people I you
serious yeah and I'm like okay because I
didn't know right and then I just
realized when I got older that they just
know how to have fun that's what it is
yeah because it's like what yeah maybe
it's expensive couple hundred bucks but
once a year well sorry not too much the
bounce house is like maybe a hundred
bucks
a hundred bucks maybe that's it that's
it
what the we got one for Tyga's birthday
and that's why because I always wanted a
bounce house too my childhood is
different than yours but I just never
asked for it because I just assumed it
was like at minimum 500 bucks
to like 30 kids I know for a whole day a
whole day the parents could chill we
were off to the side having a good ass
time because the kids were trampling
each other in that [ __ ] bounce trap
yes less than 100 bucks
my childhood sucks even more now yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] sucks yeah so because of
that
um I want to make sure taka doesn't have
my childhood he won't though and then I
I think he's CUNY and I know how
prisoners don't even have your job I
know to be honest and and because he's
so CUNY I want him to like
um you know get the things that he likes
I know how much he loves it like he
really looks like like Jiu Jitsu right
after he's done Jiu Jitsu the owner
brings out a box of snacks I know he
loves these kids so much all the kids
are so happy they can't wait for the end
they come out and then they're like
everyone picks a snack and taika is has
been doing this for like a year and a
half now picks his Oreos picks his
Fritos picks whatever
and then this time he comes and he goes
can I have a snack
and I was like
oh and then at first like so good though
I know and that breaks my heart even
more because he's not even rebelling I
know I can't have one huh and I'm like
yeah same dude [ __ ] same yesterday
same thing I don't think you went to his
practice so then I went and I forgot all
about that box and I walked by and he
goes I can't have those with my new diet
and I was like
we don't have to tell your dad well you
made it further than me because the day
before I took him Jiu Jitsu and then uh
my my brain for some reason is only
thinking about carbs are sweets so he
goes oh can I have one of these I was
like yeah so he grabbed the Fritos the
non no no no oh no no you're gonna take
it out of his hand yeah he brought it to
the car he goes oh I could have these I
don't have to eat the protein ones and
then I was like
oh I was like you do I was like I'm so
sorry
you're your [ __ ] mom I know and I was
like we'll save these for like maybe the
weekend or something okay and he goes
okay Papa
and I'm like oh my God how did you do
how could you tear it out of those
[ __ ] tiny beautiful
soft hands it is so sweet too
I know he's actually been really good
about this like I think I would have
given a lot more protest
like as a kid but he just he just he's
like he gets it yeah maybe he's just
with us like that yeah I recently went
to Trader Joe's and I bought him all
this keto food right and I'm trying to
like because kids don't know what the
[ __ ] going on so I'm trying to like
replace things that I know he likes with
Alternatives so he doesn't even know
that their alternative yeah so it
doesn't feel like his life is shifted
upside down right so I'm like okay
what's something Carby because I know as
a kid I like to eat rice and like some
Carby stuff I found him some like
cauliflower risotto so it kind of still
has that like you know dank hardiness
and then I was a morning like breakfast
food what can I get them and I'm oh
there's like these little breakfast
sandwiches he sees you and me eat
breakfast sandwiches all the time so
he'll think these are cool and then
um the other day I was like what do you
want for breakfast and then he was like
can I have one of those egg sandwiches
and even when he said that when I heard
it I was like even the way you said it
doesn't sound appetizing like what what
kid would ask for an egg sandwich but I
was like yes you can
and I [ __ ] made it for him hey I gave
him some of that cereal the Green Lace
cereal Timeless series I know but he
didn't ask for it he's just gonna have
cereal and I'm like oh I'm like Papa got
you a healthy cereal
um so then he gets it and he goes um so
he didn't know it was or maybe I don't
know I know maybe this is me projecting
my own insecurities but man this [ __ ]
keto [ __ ] sucks for him but I really
hope this does it really suck for him
though because I understand the child
there are insecurity right it's not the
insecurity no so like we understand that
childhood is Just Junk right
but it shouldn't be junk like if we
lived in a different country that
prioritized health and like more
nutritious meals we would be looking at
us you know us parents giving our kids
junk and going why would we give the
people we love the most the shittiest
[ __ ] that's a crazy good debate by the
way
let's debate it like what's childhood
okay I'm gonna paint two scenarios
is childhood
living the dream
it is okay
so is it what you see in the movies the
cheese pizza and home alone you order
that too and you have the symbiotic
relationship with the world that
everyone understands oh this brings us
happiness
or an eating like peppermint patties and
ice cream and you know like sodas and we
all have this we look at each other and
we think childhood and we look at like
Doritos and Oreos and everyone has the
same glimmer is that childhood the
United social fabric of memories is that
childhood or is childhood like the right
amino acids in your body and making sure
you have proper development I don't
think it's that obviously right but I
don't think it has to be the movies
either
right so let's say so let's say we lived
in like a Scandinavian country and in
this Scandinavian country
um everyone at that school priority
prioritizes nutrition without making it
such a like
type of thing right how do you do that
it's just it's just a lifestyle that
everyone just eats that way like it is
the lifestyle okay okay everyone has
steak and eggs instead of a Mickey Mouse
pancake exactly literally that already
sounds ridiculous wait wait okay right
so they have a protein
right and like some vegetables or some
[ __ ] so it's like it's a nutritious
hearty meal okay okay
but then the way they view movies it's
fantasy
so it's not really pitched to them as a
real thing I think once it started
changing was probably the onset of
social media to be honest with you
um because we looked at you know TV
shows or like movies and that wasn't
real life it's just this made-up thing
right did you ever see movies and you
were like that's real like you knew it
was a movie unless you're stupid I know
it's a movie
but
you still play the game
uh I guess I think it's just when it was
like okay for example right because you
guys don't even know that that's
attainable okay you watch Ninja Turtles
right you go oh Ninja Turtles right
Halloween comes around and you go what
do you want to be Scandinavian kid they
don't go oh I'd rather just be a regular
person no the even the Scandinavian kid
like I want to be a ninja turtle
s
Japanese Scandinavians yeah I don't know
you know what I mean it's like yeah it's
a movie but there's still like some sort
of like like a thing about it that you
Aspire yes and that's fine but then now
you can introduce it in moderation you
know what I mean instead of it coming
like instead of you getting a
family-sized bag of [ __ ] Doritos yeah
you can just have it on occasion
if you even want that or just making it
so that it doesn't have all these
[ __ ] nasty ingredients in it so maybe
I'm just trying to look at this whole
situation in a positive light I think
you're trying to lie to yourself maybe
maybe I am maybe I am but so I do get
sad that I'm like oh man he can't like
have what he wants but then the on the
flip side I'm also going like but it
ain't that bad that he's eating [ __ ]
grainless cereal egg [ __ ] sandwich
for breakfast like cauliflower rice like
this is all great [ __ ] yeah I mean it's
good for him right
um biologically
but
emotionally
is it taking a toll on him is he like
Memories wise he doesn't seem to mind
very much
like he'll get sad a little bit be like
oh but then again there's no protest
there's no stomping there's no
tantrum there's no like what that's why
I think it's my own insecurities yeah I
just picture him at school you know
every kid gets a and at school I let him
have whatever he wants and then he's
like
but at school at school it's
self-regulating and you know he's only
five so he's [ __ ] going off the deep
end yeah but what's dope about fiscal
that he goes to he said he for lunch he
ate biscuits which is a code word for
cookies peanut butter jelly sandwich and
then cookies after
you know so like we're doing the best we
can with the variables we can control
that at least where he's around other
normal kids yeah
he can he's he's no different yeah and I
mean he already feels different because
everyone knows he got seizures because
they've seen him get seizures you know
yeah it's cool is that he doesn't see it
as anything bad either we don't know
that he doesn't talk about it like he
did something bad I don't know maybe he
doesn't even know that he feels bad
about it well because the other day he
told me a story you know how he's going
to tell me a real story he goes Papa can
I tell you something in real life I'm
like yeah he goes I fan it the other day
and I was like really how he goes I was
in music and then I was like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa and then I grabbed
onto Paulo's arm and I fell on the
carpet
when did did we get alerted about this
or what yeah a few days ago and I was
like I was like were you okay he goes
yeah I was like I hit I fell on the
carpet and I was like okay I was like
thank you for telling me I really like
it when you tell me stuff in real life
yeah yeah
oh okay I thought this was going
somewhere else no that's it you're just
just telling me these stories oh so he's
telling you and then you inferred that
he doesn't feel bad about it because of
the tone in which he's [ __ ] yeah
yeah got it got it got it yeah because
he doesn't say like he's bad or people
are looking at him funny or why does
this happen you know it was just more
like a this is this is what happened
it's a matter of fact and then uh and
then he tried to grab on to Paulo's arm
and then that's it he fell down I'm like
okay yeah it's been hard for sure it's
been uh
um one of his teachers when we were
talking to him she says uh having kids
isn't for the wussies like it's not for
a wussy which is funny that she said
wussy because it's weasel and [ __ ] put
together but I was like all right I
don't think you know where that stems
from Miss so and such is that where
wussy comes from yeah
weasel [ __ ] really did you make that up
no I thought like hey you wuss that's
just like uh
um like a term that people say now I
gotta look it up
keep talking
no I'm gonna let you look it up oh
uh we'll see
it's not a weasel [ __ ]
wait is it a [ __ ] of a weasel
do weasels have [ __ ] yeah they're
female right
let me see
Analyze That nope was definition
the meaning I guess I don't need that
let's see yes we'll see
Wimp And a [ __ ] oh it's Wimp And a
[ __ ] it's a wimp and a [ __ ] but a new
[ __ ] was there damn that's even worse
isn't it it's like a coward it is a wimp
and a [ __ ] you wussy so isn't a wussy
technically a worse word than a [ __ ]
yeah because it's two in one so you're a
wimp and a [ __ ] so it doesn't that seem
like so you should be you should get in
more trouble if you say wussy at school
you should that's why I was like oh I
don't think you understand when you just
call would you just said I could have
sword you could say was at school maybe
they don't know where what's up you wuss
I know I don't think they know where it
comes from yeah remember were you or do
you remember when they started allowing
dick and ass on national TV yeah like on
the radio and [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
maybe yeah I was like any media I was
like does that mean I could say it at
school isn't that crazy that uh during
that time
it was like words are getting
re-released
and then now the words are getting taken
away yeah like what words like uh the r
word
oh
well
I think it's because of the way it was
used against people whereas and then the
f word whereas dick f word was never
released
that we we've never had it out no but we
could say it we could say it now they
can't even say it say it where like at
church vloggers could say it what are
you talking about you can say [ __ ] as
much as you want the other f word oh
well again because of the way it's being
used no but no one even uses it that way
that's the thing no one even uses it
that way people use it as a different
way and then they're saying you can't
use it because of this yeah right
because people were using it that way no
one even uses that way I use five what
the [ __ ] is going on I swear to God you
name one person that uses the f word
yeah Circle but there were [ __ ]
bigotry ass people using it in the wrong
way uh I don't know no people that use F
words yeah because we don't hang out
with people like that of course you
don't know any people like that well
they took away my work and I'll use them
responsibly
I guess but
um yeah that's yeah I just remember
being around and then having that happen
but yeah parenting is not for wussies
because it's fogging hard like I want to
be in the moment with him and I want to
indulge in it and just like Take It All
In
but then I also have to think about his
future and like how he's going to live
life and be a citizen and [ __ ] have
friends and I have to think of all this
[ __ ] in the future and it's so hard
because I'm like I think you're [ __ ]
cute cuss as much as you want
like I don't give a [ __ ] so like a part
of me and this is just obviously I'm not
gonna allow this at all but a very lazy
side of me is going [ __ ] I'm just gonna
have a good ass time with my kid let's
Society [ __ ]
no right it's just like I just think
about it that way right yeah I'm never
gonna act on it because hello that's
just not that's not right yeah I have
morals yeah it's unethical yeah
um so yeah Simon's going like I'm just
gonna enjoy my son whatever let him
[ __ ] deal with his own [ __ ] but
obviously you can't do that but if you
think about his wish like you you uh
were raising him on a farm
do I ever wish I was raising him on a
farm
because you know what fun like Farm life
I do it's hard Farm life looks almost
like this is our hard-ass labor this is
what we do yeah um but we also raise
kids the way we want to so we work hard
and you can do whatever you want almost
no not in that way I don't really but in
the way of like knowing a lot of skills
at such a young age yeah I do like that
no I mean like because the farm people I
know what you mean but I'm saying I
don't like I don't think about what I
mean what I'm talking about is the farm
people raise kids the way I think you
just mentioned where I'm gonna enjoy you
and let Society deal with you that's not
true the thing is the thing is you can't
say that the thing is we know a lot of
farm raised kids the adults and none of
them are like that the thing is that
Society actually never takes them
because they stay on the farm
that's not true you know what I'm saying
our very good friend Jacob
who's raised on a farm and he's the
[ __ ] dopest person on planet Earth
super polite super respectful super
considerate what are you talking about
dude super [ __ ] smart too that's
because of the farm
no no what I'm saying is I want a Savage
and then that's it but I think the farm
de Savage disguises you how because you
get it all you get the savagery out of
your system so I I really think like
classrooms and and playgrounds and stuff
it's not meant for kids
I don't think so I agree I think like
kids need to let you gotta let them
throw rocks
as many times as possible you know why
stomping puddles get all that [ __ ] out
of your system you know why they did
they do that why because they're
scientists yeah yeah and they're artists
yeah and they're musicians like they're
literally everything at once like when
we go on a hike with taika right I'm
pulling them out of school right now
like when we when we take taika on a
hike he's such an angel and it's because
the environment permits him to be right
you could throw things as much as he
wants he could stomp on Twigs
um he can make crunchy sounds whatever
he wants right he could drag a stick the
whole way through so you want me to
homeschool him because I'm down if we're
walking on the sidewalk and he's
dragging a baseball bat like yo pick it
up right so normal we see him like jump
on a puddle I'm like hey you're gonna be
wet you're gonna have to deal with the
cold I don't care okay cool over here
he's in his nice pants jump some puddle
hey what are you doing you know
yeah the thing is
how do we allow him okay so let's let's
continue this hypothetical right so we
let him be this way Farm life as you'd
like to call it right yeah
like my my thing is
do farm life people get it out of their
own system that's my thing fine I was
just going to continue just let me let
me finish let me finish okay so let's
say we do farm life right yeah so we do
farm life
but what Society is getting plugged into
because he can't stay on this Farm the
rest of his life he has to find
his own life or he becomes a Navy SEAL
but what if he doesn't want that
you gotta stay on the farm
but that's not fair either
that's tough part of being parent
okay so we found the fall in there we
found the flow in our blood that's what
I'm saying but does the farm life let
you get it out of your system you know
if you get it out of your system maybe
you are ready for society
actor
who knows I don't know I mean I'm sure
there's studies out there about this
[ __ ] but like
um what what about Farm life and is it
is it the same thing for females yeah
but I also think like a lot of females
just biologically I mean we see them
even in the animal kingdom they're
better they're just yeah they're better
they're less um
less poking at the boundaries
less uh
like you know figuring out where the
limits are it's just a little bit less
in general you know
yeah because we're not dumb like even
that uh documentary to watch on Netflix
was called Sea Wolves
like don't remind me about Cedar man the
minute like um
the territory the territory aspect
usually comes from the males yeah you
know like they're walking oh [ __ ]
another gorilla or another bear or
whatever will be like oh [ __ ] I hear the
[ __ ] bushes rustling in my territory
yeah they gotta go over there
like what's going on here you know
whereas the females are usually more
like
everybody's cool yeah I mean if you
think about the concept of schools even
Wild
you know like the structure and what in
in which just I mean I don't know what
it's like for taika school now at this
point because there's just it's just so
different from our time but like even
our time was gnarly to have these little
ass kids sit down in the same [ __ ]
place for hours yeah that's crazy bones
yeah that's crazy especially if it's
someone like you has ADD yeah it's hard
oh no wonder you got in so much [ __ ]
trouble it wasn't meant for you yeah my
Skin's just crawling can't even sit
still yeah and we come from like uh
like is is it tribes or like I don't
know like the first peoples like we just
we were out in the wild figuring [ __ ]
out it wasn't so structured and rigid
and like bells and all this [ __ ] yeah
it's cool to see a kid play though like
when I put taika in our bare backyard
right now
he could actually entertain himself for
like an hour
why wouldn't he be able to he's just
like his imagination's [ __ ] running
wild right now which is awesome because
I'm like maybe that's what kids need
more it's just a place to like just
explore and express because he could
like kick rocks and just throw them and
think about things and like can you do
that for an hour versus like being
locked up in a classroom you know and
like learn this yeah then also you need
to you gotta learn [ __ ] to be in society
exactly I know I know I [ __ ] battle
this [ __ ] I think about this [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] time all the time and I'm
always like should I put him in homes
like should I homeschool them and then
just put them in a bunch of
extracurricular [ __ ] with other kids
just so he's not the weird [ __ ]
audible they're always gonna be the odd
wall if they're homeschool too how so
what because they didn't go to prom I
didn't go to [ __ ] prom
does it matter now look how weird you
are yeah but I'm all right
are you look at your neon sweater don't
act like it's not cute
oh no yeah [ __ ] grayscale over here I
get you don't know that's normal this is
normal that is weird no
but if I'm minority that's cool
special case yeah
I don't know it's hard it's hard but
whatever one foot in front of the
[ __ ] other I guess
because there's a lot of times I think
about a bunch of [ __ ] where I'm like I
think I should just pull them all and
just have them do like extracurricular
stuff and then I'm like oh okay but I
don't want to be weird he should be with
all his classmates and I'm like but all
his classmates come from [ __ ] other
weird parents and I'm like what's the
right thing to do here yeah I also think
about friends I'm like you know when you
go to school with people and you're
there for years and you know them it's
easier to I think have deep friendships
versus if you're homeschooled I was in
the same school I didn't move around
like you did I didn't have any deep
friendships like I said you're weird
right but if you just like seeing
someone for an hour a day like Jiu Jitsu
whatever how do you make a deep friend
like that it's tough didn't even have
time to really talk I mean just because
you're yeah you don't make deep friends
either like I'm saying I I don't have
deep friends how many people do you know
that speak that that still stay in
contact with their childhood friends do
you have any silent Mike does that his
is weird David so does that and those
two are some of the most normal people
in my book do you have any of those
yeah Alec
all the time via the DMS and he's in
Taiwan I talk to him all the time
yeah maybe I am and I've known him since
we're [ __ ] sophomores in high school
yeah maybe I'm the weird one because I'm
not that tight like you're not you're
not that tight if he seems like he's an
acquaintance to you
if you ever needed something I'll be
there
yeah because we've just known each other
that long we're that comfortable you
know
like if you wanted to like stay in Vegas
you want to stay out of paddle yeah come
over
all right well then damn what the [ __ ]
do I know so I'm that's not that's the
only thing that makes me prevent
homeschooling is I feel like you make
deep relationships through proximity and
time spent yeah and so if your learning
time is just by yourself or whatever and
then the social time is quick one-hour
stints in and out it's kind of hard to
make
friendships but also don't know I'm
assuming you know yeah of course yeah we
don't know right
parenting is is uh it is challenging it
ain't for wussies no I'm saying it ain't
for wimp [ __ ] if I've ever seen one
yeah it definitely challenges you
challenge your own beliefs yeah how did
our parents do it because our parents
are dumb teacher just beat the [ __ ] out
of them it is it really beat him into a
[ __ ] box stay right here
because sometimes there's like
I don't even know if what's right or
wrong you know what I mean
you just don't you just [ __ ] just
kick it in the Box just [ __ ] don't
ruffle any feathers yeah there's
sometimes are like um
like I don't know attack it comes out of
nowhere and he's like
jumps on his head on the couch or
something and then takes off his pants
I'm like
just just don't do that
it's like
do that thing
I know what you're talking about because
he will question yeah all right and then
I go yeah why do I give a [ __ ] at night
at night maybe like 7 P.M right he's
like oh I'm gonna turn it down
he goes why are people sleeping I'm like
just
just tone it down well what I say I'm
like we like to share space
we're sharing space or like I'm not he's
not doing anything wrong you know yeah
or I'm telling him hey you need to keep
your energy down so you can just start
[ __ ] getting ready for bed or if it
doesn't make sense yeah when the morning
comes too because he's like okay cool
keep it down in the morning he comes in
the morning
why why he's like it's morning time now
I'm like just just don't do what you're
doing yeah he's [ __ ] smart I'm like
what the [ __ ] there's just so many
people just don't do it yeah he
understands so many Concepts either I
think he's really dumb so I get
surprised at some really simple [ __ ] or
he's just really smart and he gets
things he thinks outside of the box like
a [ __ ] give it to me how so he
was recently at his classmate's birthday
party right and I'm like okay this is
probably how this kid gets in trouble
all the time because he doesn't think
the way the world intends he's figuring
[ __ ] out for himself so we were at the
Children's Discovery Museum in downtown
Vegas
and do you want to give the address too
God damn that was so specific 800 a
Wonder Boy way I don't know but there's
a a pathway that goes like this right
um to like an exhibit and you know
sometimes they got to shut down exhibits
from maintenance or whatever so they put
on this Velvet Rope that blocks it
taka goes up to the Velvet Rope what do
you think he does goes underneath the
Velvet Rope and keeps walking
because you're normal
why did I get so offended right now
because that's what I thought he was
gonna do because you're normal exactly
because that's what I thought I was
gonna do right because for me I'm like
oh like
uh if he's a mischievous rebellious kid
if he sees caution tape he's gonna
I don't care about the caution tape I'm
gonna go forward
but that's still basic thinking guess
what he does
I don't know he grabs the Velvet Rope
puts his feet on the wall to see if he
could pull the Velvet Rope out of the
wall
that's not even something I'm even
thinking about
you know what I'm talking about
what why was he trying to do that little
I don't know if you just saw that like
when I saw him like as he was walking up
and my brain I was already getting ready
to pair it right like don't you do that
so I was like in my brain I was about to
as soon as I see him I jump over the
Velvet Rope or go under whatever you you
and I are both making I was gonna be
like Tyco come back here so I said I was
gonna go like this I see him going I'm
like
just just don't do that what
what the hell I don't even I don't even
know what to say I was just like what
the heck
as you're saying that it makes me think
of like
um
the way accidents happened around him
too
so like we can already we've lived
enough life that we can predict if like
if this exists here this can potentially
knock this thing over or break this
thing or whatever like we can already
see how this accident's about to happen
yeah like if you have this at the edge
of the table yeah you already know and
if you have a hundred pound German
Shepherd you just go like this because
you know he's probably gonna go like
that because that would just exactly so
you already you already know right yeah
yeah but the way so the
the way accidents happen around him I
can't even predict it yeah like let's
say that's at the edge right yeah like
this then he'll do like I don't know
he'll like be scratching his head but
then like turn to look that way then get
the ball throw it on the wall and then
it hits the [ __ ] the thing knocking
it down so I'm going
I don't even know how to parent that
because
what part of it do I like you shouldn't
have had that at the edge or don't throw
the [ __ ] ball like there was just
like so many offenses that happened and
I'm like
how do I [ __ ] coach there's this
other station where um it's this toolbox
like a big ass toolbox like imagine like
kids size [ __ ] right like when Legos are
all big like everything's big the
toolbox is like this big it's just a
tray with a handle and there's all these
mallets and Hammers and like
screwdrivers and stuff and you're
supposed to take them out and mess with
the station and do different things with
it right he walks up to it and the first
thing he tries to do is lift up the
whole toolbox off the ground but it's
bolted to the ground but you can see one
side pull them no don't do that like his
brain just doesn't work like
the other way and then there's this
other station that's an organ like
different pipes you know how when you
blow like the top of bottles like that
so the organs [ __ ] it's like um it's
pretty big and it's colorful
and uh how the organ is operated there's
vacuum tubes stuck to it so if you pull
it out it goes it'll go
[Music]
like that
he takes it out he tries to suck me with
it
oh my God so I just know he's really
creative definitely thinks outside of
the box but it catches you off guard
because you just don't know how to
parent that because you think it's like
okay it's one of two things you know
it's like if someone picks up a baseball
looks out the window you're like don't
you dare and then he swallows the
baseball you're like what what the [ __ ]
is happening it's literally what
happened
you're like what the [ __ ] literally I
couldn't even I couldn't even that was
on my list of 20 things of what he would
do yeah yeah not even other one it's not
even [ __ ] top 20.
Dennis the Menace that movie the one
with um uh grumpy old man that guy yeah
I don't know what other Dennis the
Menace exists but that particular movie
that's literally tiger because Dennis
the Menace has a [ __ ] big heart yeah
and he's just curious he thinks outside
the box and he's just trying new [ __ ]
all the time but it gets him in trouble
yeah that's literally taika like that's
why he loves literally loves that movie
so much
it's a lot man if I relates to him
do you think you were like that
I think for sure I was like that but I
think taika more so than me
damn yeah thank God we're together
because imagine like your mom trying to
raise a taika yeah I think he's more so
than me because he has us
do you know what I mean like I was
probably like Mike taika but because I
had mom who was like boom these are the
rules lay the smackdown you know then
I'm already like my world of of uh
exploration was this big it's like oh
and I'll just play here
versus taika is you know like we're also
doing it so we're also nuts and then so
like I'm not nuts well you're not as
nuts as me no I'm not because there's
times where like he does something
perfectly fine with me oh that's cool
I'm like what are you doing and I'm like
oh yeah you should we do this all the
time you know oh when you're picking up
all like the sewer not sewer caps but
there were like some caps and you were
looking at what's in there and I'm like
you're not supposed to be showing them
that one two you're not even supposed to
be lifting them up well he likes to see
the bugs underneath yeah
well yeah I should like that I do like
his reaction he looks at it oh
but he wants to keep looking at it
oh
look at that look at that Papa look at
the Cockroaches oh
might stop looking at him then let me
see one more time oh what was he eating
bell peppers no the night before where
he was like choking the bell pepper I
think it was uh yogurt when you made him
that and he was like oh my God this is
disgusting
I was like you know we're trying to be
Stern but then we look at each other
we're [ __ ] like trying nuts what was
the thing that happened
where he did something and you turned
away and just walked away I don't know I
do that a lot it was so funny I forgot
what it was but it was like literally
yesterday something happened and then
you just turned around and you walked
away and as you walk away I see you hold
it like covering your mouth I have no
idea I know bell peppers for sure he was
[ __ ] having the hardest time eating
that
God he's so [ __ ] exaggerated but then
I mean he's not exaggerated he's five
that's a five-year-olds too
yeah but he said oh my God
or like have you heard when he says that
he he said oh my God and then he looked
at me like I betrayed him
oh he like this he was like you [ __ ]
Judas although you got to eat vegetables
monkey and he goes okay I need to go oh
my God
[Laughter]
like why would you do this to me
I know I vote for him so much man
yesterday he asked me for a brother
I was like I'm trying baby I'm trying to
find the right one did you ask him uh do
you does he ever ask where Brothers come
from
well he knows babies come from stomach
right he just doesn't realize he doesn't
know that they come from like the mom so
then he said because he's like I want a
brother and I'm like
I'll get one for you baby news but I
want a human brother right so I didn't
know what he meant right so I was like I
know baby I'm I'm trying I'm trying to
find the right one and he goes oh I hope
he doesn't grow out of my belly
that sounds like I don't think he knows
what's going on I'm like I'm like I
think you're fine baby like there's
nothing's gonna happen
I hope he doesn't come out of my belly
he's the best and then uh when he thinks
he's born instead of saying like yeah
you know when I was born or whatever
he'll be like you know when you bought
me
like do you know when you picked me I
was like oh that's so cute
um have you ever heard those theories
that like
um children are still like Angels or
whatever and like they're connected to
God somehow or like their past lives
um I never heard that theory on its own
but um I feel like that's something that
is like a recurring thought in like the
whole like Dalai Lama type stuff oh oh
you know how like they'll have like a
new monk yeah and they're like oh dang
this like child has the Tendencies of
whatever like the one that passed away
and has the same beads or whatever so
they'll do like little tests and then
they're like oh damn this guy like picks
this thing or does whatever like this
guy's Reincarnation of the other kid and
then there's so many things that
um the kid has like uh leans towards
that it almost seems like this kid was
reincarnated of the passing yeah yeah
sometimes I'll ask like a
so sometimes the last type of like if he
remembers anything at a certain age and
he won't
um or sometimes he'll say stuff like oh
you know with my uncle uh with my
grandpa and I'm like what are you
talking about but then like it sounds
like he's saying like he either saw his
grandpa dreamed about his grandpa or
something so I try to like investigate
but then it leads to nothing oh but yeah
but I'm because I I think because I
think of those things that I've heard
that I'm like what's up dude want to
talk about it what do you remember what
did you say about Grandpa nothing I it
was it's something that I took a
different way yeah yeah it wasn't
anything specific to a grandpa oh yeah
it's nothing but it's just my own mind
going oh is this something but it's
never anything oh I see yeah yeah yeah
but no yeah taika is
he's one of one man my whole goal with
the whole keto thing we're doing is um
hopefully we can wean him off his meds
which has been giving him some trouble
the side effects are gnarly
um and then if we wean them off
then
um he won't have those side effects and
then he can be back to be like his
normal goofy self yeah we get to see
what that is like yeah without it
without any type of interference yeah
but putting a apply on a diet to a kid
yeah it sucks man it's [ __ ] rough
well I mean we're lucky that he's taking
to it really well yeah
because it'd be harder if the kid like I
said like if the kid was crying
yeah I think it's just my softiness you
know I mean because you've lived it you
know what it's like my insecurity and my
projection of like oh poor little
hoodies you can't you can't eat a
Tootsie Roll yeah for sure I think it's
because you've lived it
um I don't think I feel it as much as
you do because um I mean I do feel it
for sure
um but I'm like I think I'd either
convinced myself or lie to myself that
I'm like no this is
this is this is way healthier than any
other [ __ ] he doesn't need to even be
eating it is healthier for sure I mean
the stuff that we've been buying him now
it's like it's rough it's so gross
looking yeah but it's like actual Whole
Foods you know it's not like like
cinnamon toast crunch it gets delicious
but what is a snap Square for sure for
sure versus like the green look at his
[ __ ] whole nut cereal yeah that's
great there's like flax seeds sunflower
seeds like prawns and [ __ ] like that
like like that stuff's actually really
good for him do you think it's actually
uh does this show you how shitty he was
eating before is that what's actually
happening yeah but that's where we go
back to the childhood thing right where
I'm like yeah it's kind of shitty but as
Fitness parents we don't
um let them over indulge like we always
kind of keep a general monitoring oh
damn he had pizza for lunch we probably
get him something with vegetables yeah
yeah yeah for sure for sure but he's not
like on chicken fingers every single day
all day long you know so I think we'd
still do a good job of that or uh in the
morning like if you had pancakes this
morning the next morning like we'd
probably make them some eggs or
something so you kind of like keeps
balancing it out you know yeah my little
hoodies I don't know hopefully this year
we have more of a of an update with his
little brother sister and seeing what's
happening we're not pregnant this is not
an announcement but definitely still
trying because I get that question all
the time yeah so hopefully I can give
him some good news when it comes when's
our when's our actual final
maybe this year I don't know I thought
it was next year
oh sorry I meant I'm I'm already living
in 2023 baby I'm in the future yeah
2023. at the end of 2023 because that's
when you're 40. oh God that's when your
life is over over officially over my
tits are gonna drop [ __ ] two feet
they're gonna everything just sagged my
vagina just [ __ ] drops to my knees
like that's it I'm [ __ ] gray-haired
[ __ ] I'm done do you feel 40 no what do
you feel
what do I feel maybe 30s maybe like 35
32 I don't know what the difference
really is but I feel like in my early
30s I really do feel like I'm in my I
don't feel in my 20s not in terms of um
my body my body still feels the same as
it ever has if anything it feels really
good just because I train yeah
um but my mindset like I don't know like
I don't feel like hella old but I don't
feel like young and dumb yeah
my brain feels the sturdiest I've ever
been yeah and my being feels the
sturdiest I've ever yeah same which is
pretty cool it's super red because it's
way different than the way I viewed it
at least like the way I would view other
adults yeah voice things when I was a
kid yeah it almost felt like a lot of
people like oh man when you're 40 it
feels like the life's over and like I
hate people like and then 40 on to 50 is
almost a transition of becoming a
grandparent yeah and I'm like damn I
think I'm still like uh yeah getting
into my Prime I feel like for a lot of
people 40s and u30
yeah for sure for a lot of people our
generation at least
but maybe on that note
that's it that's that's it that's all
the time we got that's all the time we
got that's all the time we got okay
anything else you want to say never all
right well damn it's dope parenting with
you
let's [ __ ] try to figure this [ __ ]
out because it ain't [ __ ] easy
that's true and we're not wussies yeah
we're not woozies okay
all right anyway
um on that note thank you guys so much
for listening and we will see you next
week see you guys